good afternoon and welcome to the very
short NCBI minute about PubMed and
clinical trials my name is Ben Mosby I'm
the genomics outreach coordinator for
NCBI I'll be presenting this webinar and
I have with me Peter Cooper and Cathy
Kay nice from the NCBI education group
and PubMed respectively who can help to
answer your questions many researchers
clinicians and medical librarians are
very interested in clinical trials.gov
which is a registry of clinical trials
what I'd like to show you today is a
very quick and easy way to filter your
PubMed results by those that are also in
clinical trials.gov if we were to search
for cancer and G protein in PubMed we'd
find about 25,000 results one could look
for article types under clinical trial
also you could go to our advanced search
page and there are many many options
there on which you can filter however
I'd like to show you an even easier way
to get into that information today so
from individual abstracts we've actually
added clinical trials.gov numbers and
there's a direct link right at the
bottom of the PubMed abstract as you can
see here but a very easy way to find
things that are in clinical trials.gov
is to put clinical trials.gov
directly in the pubmed search box
however the really neat thing is that
you can combine clinical trials.gov with
say a particular type of cancer and
g-proteins
to get a very narrow down view of this
the reason we made this webinar is a lot
of people ask us questions related to
this topic if you have other questions
that you're interested in finding out
about please check out our webinars
aged under the archived webinars and
courses tab there are many many webinars
that you can check out and also there's
a lot of documentation for many of our
resources that said if you're interested
in seeing a particular topic for a
webinar please email us at webinars at
NCBI dot NLM nih.gov with that we'd like
to take any questions that you may have
the first question I have I'd like to
address the kavika niece and the
question is have you gone backwards in
time to add clinical trials numbers
abstracts in PubMed yes so that we
actually have exposed any abstract or
citation I should say that had a
secondary source ID clinical trial
number but was not included in the
abstract we are now exposing that
information so that you don't have to
open up the secondary source or mesh
section on an abstract so we're moving
that information directly under the
abstract and we're adding the link
directly to clinical trials.gov thanks
Kathy in a related question someone asks
how far back will clinical trials at the
end of abstracts go ah I don't know we
can run a search right now I'm not
certain if we go to PubMed and just type
in sorry one second here if you just
type in clinical trials gov into the
search bar and press search you'll see
in the right-hand discovery column a
results by year and you we've got
information back to 2000 there are two
citations in 2000 and then they continue
on throughout the years if you hover
over that results by year diagram you
can see the individual accounts broken
down by year thanks Kathy yep so one
more related question
well adding clinical trials.gov just
take you to PubMed abstracts that have
it and CT number I think you partially
answered this question before right so
if you just search for clinical
trials.gov we're looking for that phrase
in the title in the abstract or in the
secondary source ID field so if that
phrase doesn't exist then where the
information will not be there however
there is a filter that you can use and
that is clinical trials gov no period
and bracket it with filter or subset and
you'll be able to see all of the links
that are curated between the clinical
trials.gov database and pubmed
so if you type in clinical trials gov no
period and press ENTER you'll reach out
retrieve 209 thousand citations and when
you click on an abstract for those
citations you will see a link out button
that will go to the clinical trials
database unfortunately those those icons
are sometimes delayed by 24 or 48 hours
so you won't probably want to skip to
the next like two or three pages let's
see if I can find so I will check on
that filter but you should be able to
see a link out icon that goes directly
to the clinical trials.gov database so a
lot of the other questions are
tangentially related so we're gonna go
ahead and respond to those offline if
there are novel questions we'll go ahead
and put them on the answers on our FTP
site I would like to thank Kathy for her
time and I guess the one thing I want to
reiterate is if you use the filter
they're going to be indexed way farther
back then if you use the clinical
trials.gov search I hope this has been
very useful to you and if you have
further questions please feel free to
email webinars and NCBI
nlm nih.gov and we'll be happy to try to
answer them thanks a lot and have a
great day we hope to see you at future
and CBI webinars